why does this country have so many more
deaths accidental deaths suicide deaths
homicides by gun than the other
countries there's one reason we have
more guns per capita than anybody else
does there is on the order of four times
as many defensive gun uses by victims as
there are criminal uses by offenders the
gun in the home is 21 times more likely
to be used against you and a family
member than it is to protect you from an
intruder self-defense with a gun is
almost perfectly effective and relative
to other forms of self-protection
it's more effective two to three people
are killed with a gun accidentally
everyday oftentimes young children
people will use guns for self-protection
have you know basically one result they
come out of it okay the bad guy doesn't
take their gun away from them and they
don't get injured or lose property
welcome to this first debate of the
third season of the so forum and thank
you all for making our first two seasons
such a success and making a third season
possible we're at the subculture Theatre
in downtown Manhattan we're not only
being videoed by reason we're also being
videoed by c-span so if you ask a
question you will be immortalized I'm
I'm Jean Epstein director of the solo
forum and tonight's resolution reads our
first compound sentence for a resolution
not too complicated to follow I believe
while laws that restrict gun ownership
would reduce crimes perpetrated by
criminals , that benefit will be more
than offset by the forgone opportunities
for defensive gun use by victims of
crime now you'll see on the walls here
the Wi-Fi so that you can go into solo
vote.com
many of you are familiar with it take
out your cell phone's going to solo
vote.com will you'll see the resolution
and you can vote yes/no or undecided and
when we finish the debate as many of you
know according to Oxford cell voting you
will vote once again yes/no or undecided
this program was written for us by a
friend of my stepsons who works on the
driverless car in Silicon Valley he
assured me that the only way for your
vote to be registered as if you vote
once each time if you vote once and you
know about the second time you're not
registered but the second time and don't
were the first not registered you can't
vote more than once he said it was easy
enough to write this program it's
foolproof and very good and the tally of
course it is practically immediate so
again please vote while laws that
restrict gun ownership would reduce
crimes perpetrated by criminals that
benefit would be more than offset by the
forgone opportunities for defensive gun
use by victims of crime now I'll get a
general announcement that I made last
month for the first time ever and not to
be repeated for a long time the sole
form will not be held this month next
month in this theatre at the Seoul forum
at the at the subculture theatre here it
will be held at the Jarrell Lynch
theatre at John Jay College at tenth
Avenue and 59th Street that has three
times the capacity of this hall and we
renting it because it will be a debate
about socialism and we know that there
are a lot of socialists in Manhattan and
the Bronx Queens and Staten Island who
would like to come alexandria Acacio
cortez
if anybody who know her tell her ten
free tickets for her and her entourage
if she'd like to come and we think it's
fairly easy to fill a hole of 600
certainly with our own following and as
well with all the Socialists we can
possibly sell tickets to the the
resolution will be socialism is more
effective than capitalist
in bringing prosperity and freedom to
the masses that resolution will be
defended by Bhaskar Sankara the editor
and publisher of Jacobin magazine and an
officer of Democratic socialists of
America in New York City the person
taking the negative side of the
resolution will be me and we will of
course have a guest moderator so I want
all of you to come however you feel
about socialism and capitalism I think
you'll be interested to hear a clash
about this fundamental issue I will say
that I think the argument I'm gonna make
about capitalism versus socialism could
be an argument that even you have never
heard very probably an argument that
Bhaskar has never heard especially well
we are as I say it's sponsored by reason
The Reason Foundation they do have
videos they handle our bills they do a
lot for us they also oh my god what
happened to the magazines we were
distributing magazines that we brought
them so we will be distributing Breeze
in magazines and I want to bring Nicol
SP to the stage briefly Nick are you in
the theater and ready to come to the mic
to talk about reason reason magazine and
this special subject that the magazine
is about take it away look sorry thank
you so much Jane thank you everybody for
coming please make sure to look for the
issues and take them and if you're
already a subscriber give them to
somebody who hates freedom free minds
and free markets you know give them
something to think about I will only say
very briefly we are 50 years old this
year Reason magazine was founded in 1968
and on November 3rd in Los Angeles we're
going to be celebrating our fiftieth
anniversary with a huge party please go
to reason.com and look at what we're
offering and think about coming out to
LA I know it's a long trip from the
subculture theater in NoHo but it'll
definitely be worth the time so thank
you all and thank you Jean and looking
forward to a great debate tonight
in fact it's an extra added attraction
on November 1st in LA there will be a
solo forum debate we're working on on a
good one so for a brief shining moment
in November the sole form will be
bicoastal so if you want to come out
early that November first debate will
soon to be announced that will be held
as well well at every almost every soul
forum we have a warm-up act and this
time we have the return of the great
Dave Smith a post a part of the problem
Dave
please come to the stage and tell us how
not to be part of the problem thank you
hello hello is that on yeah sound good
all right yeah I have another round of
applause for Jean Epstein everybody
Reason magazine I I'm thrilled to be
back I love these these events they're
always a lot of fun like I'm looking
forward to this one I'm looking forward
to the next one when Jean debates we're
filling a hall with 600 socialists what
could go wrong that looks like a great
plan according to history am I the only
one who feels that we might be walking
into an ant Aoife trap on that next one
because I was gonna walk right in and
catch a bike lock over the head but I
luckily I'll have my gun on me I'm all
right
I'm just kidding I mean I I like guns
but I'm in New York City jus I've never
been close to one so I just I like other
people to carry them near me
guns what a great great topic for a
debate little outdated if you ask me I'm
more of a plastic straw guy but I guess
we could still talk about guns it's kind
of 2012 if you ask me but plastic straws
that's what we need a ban that's the
real problem
do you know how many people die because
of plastic straws every year none but
do you know how many people could
potentially die because of plastic
straws billions so so just something to
think about on your way home later on
today I'm actually I'm fairly
disappointed in all of you guys this is
you know you could have been voting
today and instead you came here you had
a chance to put what's-her-name from Sex
in the City into the governor's mansion
and you blew it by coming to this event
did you see all of the people out
telling you to vote today they're like
on every corner there's someone like
it's election day are you voting in the
primary nothing's ever made me more
furious in my life like are they
actually wasting taxpayer dollars with
someone on the corner to tell me to go
vote is that how terrible things are
that you need to be like go vote and or
like I'd rather stab myself in the eyes
than vote it's like how do I get a
choice between a corporatist Democrat
and a socialist let me think about this
all day and then I was like someone
someone just on the corner right here
asked me it was like are you gonna vote
today and I just said I'm going to the
Soho forum and kept walking he had no
idea what I was talking about but I felt
pretty satisfied inside really that's
all that matters when it comes down to
it guns I don't I'll be honest I'm
always like a little bit too radical for
whatever the resolution of the debate is
like the resolution is like even though
what is it that guns would reduce crime
from criminals and I'm already like you
blew it blew it right there that's way
too much of a concession for me with
reduced crime from criminals I mean sure
if you're only counting the private
criminals but we've got the biggest gang
in the universe in New York City the
NYPD did you see all of them they just
went down they just arrested like six of
them for running a prostitution and
gambling ring the other day what does
that does that not count as like gun
crime they all have guns on them right I
mean um don't get me wrong I was kind of
like where do they do all this stuff but
at the same time it's a little bit
outrageous that like really cops are
running a gambling
esta tution drink that's that's terrible
it's on 33rd Street you say okay alright
I'll do whatever whatever I'll be
looking into it it's not I don't even
care but where exactly what train is the
nearest one so that it's a six train
right okay don't figure how are the cops
that's what they never count when they
talk about criminals right they never
talk about the cops but if it was any
other group going around with guns that
were just like kidnapping and harassing
people we'd probably be like we have a
pretty big gang problem here in New York
but if they're wearing a blue uniform
and a badge everyone's like oh no it's
just when you go to deal with you know I
hate the cops unless there's any cops
here in which case I totally love cops
I don't know I just joking around
comedian telling jokes you're doing a
great job but if there's no cops here I
hate them I can't stand them my friend
he's like a he was like a left-wing guy
and he used to go out and like protest
the cops like before black lives matter
got completely insane he used to go on
those things and like I remember he said
once to me he was like you know the
thing about the cops that's infuriating
is that they work for us and I remember
just laughing and I was like no they
don't that's the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever
heard in my entire life they don't work
for us and he was like no but you know
the way the system works they're
supposed to work for us like we pay our
tax dollars and that pays their salary
so they work for us and I was like yeah
but you're leaving out a crucial element
of that equation you don't choose to pay
your tax dollars you [ __ ] have to
someone doesn't work for you if you have
to pay them some only works for you if
you choose to pay them that would be
like if someone mugged you and then you
were like I guess that guy works for me
now I'm an
I mean I'm paying his salary after all
so look at that I wasn't even planning
on hiring a new employee today but look
at that guy gosh I got the job it's
pretty impressed with that guy he got
the job and he came into the job
interview with the wrong attitude let me
tell you that you came from him just
cursing at the boss still walked out
with the job you know okay
I have been mugged before in my life I
grew up in Brooklyn and not like this
new hipstery Brooklyn that you guys are
used to I grew up in Brooklyn when it
was like you know dangerous and yeah
that's there's my experience with guns I
had a gun pulled on me once it was about
15 years ago and I was walking home to
where I lived at the time in Brooklyn it
was late at night it was like 3:00 in
the morning and I was walking home and
this like he was like a thug II looking
kid but he was a kid like he was like 15
if I had to guess and this 15 year old
just came up to me and I was right
outside my apartment building and he
goes give me your wallet and I was like
nah that's adorable
and you know like I'm not the toughest
guy in the world but he was like 15 and
in my mind I was like I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of this 15 year old kid you
know when do you ever get to just
fistfight a 15 year old I was pretty
excited like this is my moment to shine
and and I and he was like give me your
wallet and I was like now I don't think
so and then he pulled out a gun and then
I was like you know what I do think so I
think I am gonna give you my wallet I
backed down right away gun really
changes the equation like with he was
like give me your wallet and I was like
no way and then he pulled out the gun
and I was like hey bro what are we
arguing about you know like take my
wallet my wallet what we calling it my
wallets your wallet take your wallet
Thanks thanks for letting me hold your
wallet for all these years that was cool
of you man
and a lot of people think it's like
scary with the idea of having a gun
pulled on you like people be like oh
weren't you terrified but really it's
not that scary in the moment it's just
it's like a lot of adrenaline you get
scared afterward but in the moment
you're just very focused you're like I
need to get from point A to point B like
point a gun point be alive and safe
somewhere else and so I you know just
like gave him my wallet was like okay
alright take it and he took it and and
then he ran off into the night and then
you know like what just happened started
to hit me and I was just overcome with
anger like the type of anger you can
only experience when a child takes your
wallet but I can't believe it this
fifteen-year-old just took my wallet
outside my home and I was so angry that
I couldn't even think right and I'm
right this is a true story okay this is
what I did I ran into my apartment and I
grabbed my biggest kitchen knife and
then I ran back out after the kid and
and I got outside my apartment and I was
on the street and then I just had like a
moment of clarity when the adrenaline
started dying down and I just looked at
the knife in my hand and I was like dude
what is the plan here what am I gonna
catch this kid and then he's gonna pull
the gun back out and I'm gonna be like
oh yeah that's right gone that's what
this whole thing was about it was about
gone and then I'll just wimp out again
once I see the gun and I'll be like you
forgot your knife all right sorry I
don't know let's tell here I just didn't
want you to leave without your knife
thanks again for letting me hold your
wallet all right have a good one
yeah all right I'm very much looking
forward to the debate thanks guys for
coming out Thank You gene for having me
have a good one everybody
[Music]
Thank You Jerry swifty does a great
podcast called part of the problem a lot
of good insights and a lot of great
jokes on that show I this I'm a regular
listener well let me put this down
announce the main event to defend the
resolution we have Professor Gary click
Gary please come to the stage taking the
negative on the resolution we have
professor Paul Helmke Paul please come
to the stage
Bret please close the voting thank you
we have closed the voting in the initial
vote and now Gary you are there to
defend the resolution about guns we've
read a couple of times please come to
the podium resolution Thank You Jean and
I'm happy the voting was done before you
got a chance to get a good look at me
all right the proposition really has two
points and I only want to make two
points number one if you actually banned
guns it's going to primarily affect non
criminals and that's the non
controversial part of what I'll have to
say and secondly there's a harm in
taking guns away from good guys which is
where the controversy ends and resume
first of all let's let's define what we
mean by a prohibitionist gun control law
by definition it means you're trying to
take guns away from everybody
theoretically legally speaking it
applies to everyone equally criminals
and non criminals alike but in practice
that's not going to be the case
the NRA may have been a little over the
top when they said when guns are
only outlaws will have guns but a more
moderate way of phrasing the same basic
idea is if you tell everybody they can't
have guns the people likely us to obey
the law that says you can't have guns
are the law-abiding I mean it's true by
definition it's not really a
controversial point so what that implies
is you will proportionally reduce the
share of non criminals who have guns
whose only involvement in crime would be
as victims then it would be the
proportional drop in gun ownership among
criminals it's just because the
compliance with the law will be higher
among non criminals and criminals well
that in turn means that gun uses by non
criminals will be affected more so
you'll reduce defensive uses of guns by
non criminal victims more then you'll
reduce criminal uses by offenders just
because of who it is that would obey the
law so if you're really Pro control and
you favor banning guns you don't really
care about taking guns away from non
criminals you figure well you know add
worse maybe a few hunters won't be able
to shoot Bambi so big deal there's no
serious harm until you take a count of
self-defense with a gun and for years
the myth was well you know it's crazy to
try to defend yourself with a gun
because the criminal only take it away
and use it against you it's completely
mythical you know when when pressed for
examples of that happening advocates of
gun prohibition came up empty it just
doesn't happen
and I systematically looked into it
using the National Crime Victimization
survey data which is a huge scale
national survey done by the Census
Bureau that asks people about their
crime victimization experiences and
nobody has that experience people will
use guns for self-protection
have you know basically one result they
come out of it
okay the bad guy doesn't take their gun
away from them and they don't get
injured or lose property so where did
this notion that self-defense with a gun
is a bad thing come about people would
be able to cite examples where somebody
used a gun defensively and was injured
only here's the little detail they left
out they got injured first and then out
of desperation use the gun for
self-protection well it can hardly be
use of the gun that caused them to get
hurt because they got hurt first and for
a long time the survey in question
didn't get out that detail of sequence
it turns out virtually nobody who uses a
gun for self-protection is then
subsequently hurt likewise virtually
nobody loses property in short
self-defense with a gun is almost
perfectly effective and relative to
other forms of self-protection it's more
effective that is to say anything else
you could do running away yelling for
help fighting without a weapon calling
the cops your name and anything else
we're doing nothing it doesn't work as
well as using a gun for self-protection
and by using it I mean it's it's usually
just threatening with a gun it rarely
involves shooting and when it involves
shooting often it's just shooting up in
the air it's a you know a warning shot
and it hardly ever involves good guy
shooting and wounding bad guy so it's
basically threatening a criminal with a
gun is almost always effective now the
evidence for this is overwhelming
there's really no serious dispute about
that where big dispute came about was
how often does this happen okay maybe
it's effective but who cares it
practically never happens you know crime
victims almost never have the chance to
use a gun for self-protection and in a
place like New York City that's true if
you're not carrying a gun
if you don't have a gun you can't use
the gun for any purpose but in the rest
of the world or the rest of the United
States anyway people are armed to the
teeth it used to be a point of
propaganda that we had way too many guns
and there were more guns than people and
it wasn't true 30 40 years ago it's true
now there's over 350 million guns in
private hands now
and the big boost was the Obama effect
you know Barack Obama would make noises
about various kind of gun control
measures and everybody raced out and
bought whatever kind of gun they didn't
already own so and he'd make jokes about
it you know you'd say always the biggest
friend of the gun industry they ever had
well what we know about how often
defense of gun use occurs in the country
as a whole is again the National Crime
Victimization survey well the problem
with that though is it's a non anonymous
survey done by the federal government so
somebody who works for the government
and it was reporting to the Justice
Department that is the law enforcement
branch of the federal government is
asking the questions in a non anonymous
survey not surprisingly this does tend
to discourage people from reporting a
defense of gun use so we unfortunately
have to use other sources of information
and there have now been over 20 national
surveys that have asked the question
have you used a gun for self-protection
and they use representative probability
samples of the population so that you
can project to the population as a whole
how many defensive gun uses there were
the estimates range from 1 to 3 million
huge numbers and to put that in in
perspective most years there are fewer
than 500,000 crimes in which the
offender used a gun so there is on the
order of four times as many defensive
gun uses by victims as there are
criminal uses by offenders so now
combine that with original premise I
started with which is if you ban guns
for everybody in theory the way it works
out and
practices you'll reduce defensive gun
use as proportionally defensive gun uses
by non-criminals more than you'll reduce
criminal uses by crime offenders and so
you've got guns that are used for
self-protection huge numbers of times
and that are used very very effectively
to reduce injury if you get rid of all
that defensive gun use the implication
is those people who would have used a
gun but now can't are more likely to be
injured you would therefore have more
injuries mostly non-fatal but some fatal
as a result of denying guns to people
who could have used them effectively for
self-protection
so only reserve the rest of my time to
Paul he'll need it
[Music]
well there's no there's no trading you
can't pay for the minutes you do get 15
okay Gary Gary took less than 10 you can
take you 15 if you want well first of
all just thank you all for being here
thank you for the invitation it's it's
been ten years since I debated Gary I
think we had a three-on-three debate
where I debated Gary John Lott and Steve
Halbrook from a lawyer for the NRA and
this is my second time with with gene
and one of his debates I debated John
Mladic two and a half years ago I think
it was at your former venue and always
enjoy having the chance to to discuss
this issue I I I come to this issue from
from multiple backgrounds I was a lawyer
in Fort Wayne Indiana for years I was a
mayor in Fort Wayne Indiana I run the
police department I I dealt with the
issue of crime and defensive gun uses
and criminal gun use is quite a bit as
head of the police department after I
left the mayor's office I later took a
job as head of the Brady Campaign and
the Brady Center to Prevent Gun Violence
where we tried to lobby for some common
sense what I considered common sense gun
laws the and now I'm a professor at
Indiana University in Bloomington
Indiana
I don't do research I look at things
more from a law and a policy side Gary
does all these research and statistics
and regression theories that go over my
head but I'm always happy to debate
these sorts of issues this issue is a
complicated issue it's a complicated
proposition Gary's treating it as a as
sort of prohibitionist and one of the
versions of the of the resolution was
prohibitionism I think the final one
that gene announced was while laws that
restrict not prohibit gun ownership and
reduce crimes
the benefit would be more than offset by
the defense of gun uses will forget the
proposition I think the main issue here
is our guns more of a benefit or are
there more costs that come from guns is
our system one that that that in that
puts more costs or more benefits on us
and our our present system doesn't
prohibit guns I don't know anyone who
really argues for a prohibition of guns
with 350 million guns out there it's
considered a lost cause even if someone
would want to but Gary talked a lot
about what he saw some of the benefits
of having guns when we talk and guns can
be used defensively guns can be a
benefit but clearly there are costs with
guns and I think before we get into the
issue of how many defensive gun uses
there are and doing the cost-benefit
analysis let's just briefly review the
costs that go along with guns in this
country today basically we have two to
three accidental deaths by a gun every
day two to three people are killed with
a gun accidentally every day oftentimes
young children they're the stories you
read the five-year-old finds the gun and
kills the three-year-old sister
there's the teenager they didn't know
the gun was loaded that's one of the
reasons I came to this issue I had a
friend that was shot in the back when
other friends thought the gun wasn't
loaded
two to three accidental gun deaths per
day in this country and I might mention
that that you know that's you know that
that's that's quite a few that's a lot
more than other countries experience in
terms of accidental gun deaths every day
there's also 55 suicides by gun now a
lot of people say what's that got to do
with this whole issue we're not talking
you know they're not criminals that's
not accidental what what you know
suicides are gonna happen regardless we
have more suicides by guns than any
other country and one of the things when
you talk to people that deal with mental
health issues that deal with suicide
prevention is that if if someone's
thinking that they want to commit
suicide and there's a lot of discussion
about this is really a cry for help you
know you want some intervention it's a
spur-of-the-moment type thing some you
know it's different obviously in
different situations basically almost
every other way that you try to commit
suicide your success quote success rate
might be 10 to 20 percent if you use a
gun it's 90 to 95 percent so we end up
with 50 suus 55 suicides per day in this
country then we have homicides we
average about 32 gun homicides per day
in this country
that's a Virginia Tech happening every
day in this country and nobody pays too
much attention to it and that's
in the mass shooting so those 90 to 100
type deaths are happening with the gun
every day in this country those are the
costs of our current gun policy and for
every death with a gun there's another
two to three people that are injured
with that gun and survived they survived
the accidental shooting or the homicide
attempt or the suicide attempt and they
live with that gun injury oftentimes the
rest of their life these are the people
like Jim Brady who was killed I was
accidentally I mean who was it was
injured seriously injured in the in the
assassination attempt on President
Reagan he Layton died just a couple
years ago they attributed his death
actually to that shooting but he lived
with that every day of his life for
30-plus years
it's Gabby Giffords who got that bullet
in her brain in Tucson in 2011 how
that's affected her and for every one of
those gunshot victims
you've got the families and who survived
you've got their families and their
friends and their co-workers that are
helping to bear the costs that are
seeing the pain that they're seeing the
suffering you know I still remember them
one of the last nights I spent with Jim
Brady I was at his house and I could
hear him scream every time he rolled
over in the bed and those were from
injuries that have been happened 25
years earlier there's continuing costs
for all of us
then there's the direct cost the medical
cost the lost productivity estimates go
from anywhere from 6 million for the
direct costs half of which are paying by
the taxpayer some people go up to even a
billion dollars in costs in terms of the
impact of gun violence in this country
gun violence in this country
per head gives us a very serious cost
now is this normal you know maybe this
is just part of a part of what life's
like no children under 15 our 9 times as
likely to die of an accidental shooting
in this country then in the rest of the
developed world that's children under 15
9 times as likely to die of the
accidental shooting here then another
civilized developed nations in 1992 our
murder rate was 5 times that of the
other frontier English frontier
countries Australia New Zealand and
Canada most of those murders were gun
murders
ten times the suicide rate by guns in
this country than in the other 25 most
developed countries 10 times more
suicide by guns it's in every 17 times
more gun homicides in this country than
in the other civilized countries why
does this country have so many more
deaths accidental deaths suicide deaths
homicides by gun than the other
countries there's one reason we have
more guns per capita than anybody else
does
when you look at these 350 million guns
that makes a difference and it makes a
difference when the studies and I'm not
the expert I haven't done the research
but there are people that have published
their studies that show that a gun in
the home is 21 times more likely to be
used against you and a family member
than it is to protect you from an
intruder often a lot of that's the
suicide but sometimes it's the
accidental shooting sometimes it's
picking up the gun and shooting the
brother-in-law and you don't expect them
to come in in the middle of night 21
times more likely to be used against you
or a family member than it is to protect
you
there's been some studies that show
those who carry a gun are four times
more likely to get shot than those who
don't carry now these aren't necessarily
causation things that's what's so tricky
in this thing people that have the gun
in their home might be more dangerous
neighborhoods people to carry the gun
might be more dangerous professions
women the woman's that women have a risk
of being a domestic homicide victim
their risk of being a domestic homicide
victim increases seven times if there's
a gun in their home
guns make things more dangerous and
there are a lot of studies out there
that basically say that the more guns
you have in a house in a County in a
state in a country the more gun violence
you're gonna have that includes all the
homicides the suicides and the
accidental shootings there are
tremendous costs to having gun violence
to having to our gun policy tremendous
cost of gun violence in our country and
that's something that needs to be taken
to account one thing I learned is mayor
when you look at crime statistics too is
that there's a lot of variation you've
got different reports different ways of
looking at things
one of the hardest numbers to fudge are
deaths and so when you look at those
numbers of deaths you
something significant okay so there's
cost serious cost to our current gun
policy now gary argues that there are
benefits though to having guns and sure
sometimes a good guy with the gun stops
the bad guy with a gun
sometimes Jason Bourne James Bond John
Wayne whoever it is is there to stop the
bad guy but the statistics are all over
the place
Gary's a rekha initial study on this
said that there were about 2.4 defensive
gun uses each year in in this country
there's a group called the gun violence
archive that looks at like every
newspaper every police report they can
find on a daily basis obviously not
everything gets reported they came up
four with two thousand twenty one
hundred defensive gun uses in all of
2017 just a little over two thousand
that's the bottom line probably but
that's looking at police reports that's
looking at newspaper studies across the
country to try to find some evidence
that there have been defensive gun uses
the National Crime Victimization study
that goes back to people twice a year
that follows up with information they
come up with 100,000 defensive gun uses
each year gary comes up with 2.4 million
where did this number come from again
I'm not the expert there's all sorts of
arguments about false positives and how
people are on unwilling to you know will
they'll say that they've done a
defensive get gun use when they really
haven't Gary argues that there's also
false negatives but you know you get
those if you want those debates there's
there's tons of scholars to do this I've
I've noticed when you read scholarly
literature they're actually nastier than
politicians it's amazing it's a you know
they're that they keep running there's
there's concerns with rare events when
you're looking about something that
happens only 1% or 2% of the time
obviously it doesn't take too many
people reporting falsely or remembering
things poorly to get the number up
higher there's the problem with
telescoping yes I use the gun but maybe
it was three years ago and you're only
asking about the last two years the
National Crime Victimization
he tries to correct for those things by
going back to the same people and
following up with the same questions
there's questions of sampling Gary's
originals sampling which had 5,000
people on I read the whole thing the
other night talks about how it over
sampled for males and people in the
south and the West just because they
knew they needed to do he knew he needed
to do that in order to get more people
in the survey then he adjusts for it
with a number but if you adjust the nut
with if you make the adjustment wrong
then that can throw the numbers up I
don't know all those things Gary can
answer those in argue those better
there's other scholars that can do it
but the numbers vary that's what I'm
trying to point out when I make policy
as a mayor I say what are the numbers
and somebody says it's two thousand
somebody says a hundred thousand gary
says it's 2.4 million try to explain to
me why there is so much discrepancy here
gary studies interesting that with some
of the things they come up with and it
makes me wonder about the the studies
not only are there issues about these
defensive gun uses not showing up on
police reports these defensive gun uses
don't show up in hospital reports they
don't show up in emergency room reports
gary says bad guys when they're shot
don't go to the hospital so maybe that
takes care of it but there's other
things there according to Gary studies
when someone is confronted by a bad guy
and they fire at them they hit their
target 53 percent of the time it's a 53
percent hit rate and Gary's original
study which is something that police
officers don't don't bet you know that
that's something that's unheard of I
mean that's you're in a shootout
situation the Adrenaline's flowing and
they're hitting their target 53 percent
of the time another interesting thing in
Gary's thing is that 46 percent of
defensive gun uses are by women this
isn't in the early 90s now maybe that's
true but it's didn't fit doesn't fit
with any of the rest of the literature
women don't own guns at the same rate
women don't fire guns at the same rate
women aren't involved in the gun culture
at the same rate but 46 percent of
Gary's defensive gun uses are women but
the most amazing thing is is Gary's
conclusion based on his survey that
there have been three hundred and forty
thousand to four hundred thousand lives
saved people
say for murder by defensive gun uses in
a single year now think of that I've
already pointed out when you have 32
homicides a day maybe we're doing
fifteen to twenty thousand homicides a
year in this country but Gary's good
guys with the guns are saving almost
400,000 each year something doesn't fit
here the numbers don't make sense to me
and I think that's one of the problems
that this whole discussion last point I
want to make them is even if Gary's
numbers are right or if they're
somewhere in this range between the
hundred thousand and on the national
crime study in Gary study are these
necessarily beneficial positive gun uses
this is the other fast name thing what
are some of the categories that that is
considered that are considered defensive
gun uses Gary's original study counts
saying I've got a gun is the defense of
gun use in other words I've got a gun
don't yell at me okay
defensive gun use only one half of those
only one half of those people that had a
defensive gun use even pointed the gun
at the offender forty-seven percent said
that there was no threat or attack for
their defense of gun use excuse me if
there's no threat and there's no attack
how is it a defensive gun use and you're
not pointing your gun it's not it and
it's a defensive gun use 52 percent of
the offender's - 52 percent of the bad
guys were unarmed and only 18 according
to the survey only 18 percent of the
offenders had guns something's wrong
here you know there's a lot of arguments
over whether these defensive gun uses
are effective some studies show that
you're just as likely to get injured
with a gun without a gun some people say
you're just as likely to get injured if
you got a baseball bat or even in better
shape with you got a gun obviously the
numbers don't add up
what does add up is we've got
significant costs and the defensive uses
are questionable I think we can find a
way basically to say let's reduce the
bad things from happening without taking
the good things away thank you
[Applause]
Gallery Roboto you can get up at the
podium if you want for the bottle I
recommend that okay
first of all we need to make clear that
the term prohibitionist covers a lot of
ground now of course the Brady Campaign
which Paul used to head is it's not
advocating a complete ban on all
firearms that would be pointless I mean
it's a political impossibility
however the organization has favored a
ban on handguns in fact they they they
did this openly until the 70s and then
they kind of did it covertly thereafter
for example they fire filed an amicus
curiae I brief on behalf of Washington
DC's handgun ban when it was challenged
and ultimately ruled unconstitutional
they were saying we need to preserve
this handgun ban if that's not favoring
banning handguns if that's not favoring
handgun prohibition I don't know what is
well that was ruled unconstitutional you
couldn't favor that anymore so they now
favor banning so-called assault weapons
which are not military weapons they can
fire like machine guns they're just
ordinary wildly popular guns owned
almost overwhelmingly by non criminals
and used for non criminal purposes that
fire one shot at a time and they favor
banning those they also favor banning
magazines that hold more than ten rounds
again which are not used by mass killers
to boost the the casualty count in mass
shootings they're used almost almost
entirely by non criminals for non
criminal purposes Paul refers to the
fatality rates for suicides being many
times higher for attempts with guns than
for other attempts as if we ought to
compare guns with the entire set of all
other suicide methods as if people would
be as likely to substitute the least
lethal methods of suicide if they
couldn't get a gun and
put the gun to their head and pull the
trigger that's implausible they would
instead favor whatever is the next most
lethal method of killing themselves
which is hanging here's the little
secret he didn't share with you there's
no significant difference between the
fatality rates of attempts by hanging
and attempts by shooting they're both
about 80% fatal
he says guns are 21 times more likely to
be used against gun owners than they are
against the criminal that's not true but
it's a it's a myth that will not die the
studies it was based on in similar
ratios they didn't count all defensive
gun uses or even most of them are even
more than a tiny fraction they covered
killings
how many times are civilians are the you
know the law-abiding people killed how
many times are the gun owners killed and
how many criminals did they kill as if
the point of having a gun for
self-protection
is to pile up bodies on your doorstep
that's not the point the point is to
save lives
to prevent injury and you can't count up
the number of lives saved or injuries
prevented so that ratio has absolutely
no relevance at all it's basically a
cost-benefit ratio in which you counted
up the cost and didn't count up any of
the benefit the benefit is not in
killing criminals it's in avoiding being
killed yourself or injured yourself or
losing property yourself she says more
guns lead to more gun homicide well yeah
duh that's true more gun homicides you
can't commit a gun homicide unless you
have a gun the issue is do you kill more
people when there's more guns is there a
higher homicide rate overall no there is
not all of the best methodologically
soundest research without exception
finds places with higher gun ownership
rates do not have higher total homicide
rates they also don't have higher total
suicide rates they just have a higher
percentage of homicides and suicides
involving guns
he seriously cites as evidence of how
often defensive gun use occurs the
number of newspaper accounts or news
accounts I compiled in the gun violence
archive and says there were 2000 yeah
there probably are 2000 defensive gun
uses where somebody was crazy enough to
actually report it to the police which
in turn got reported to the local news
media but that has nothing to do with
how many are committed total overall it
has absolutely nothing to do with it
because you'd be crazy to either tell
the police or the news media or anybody
else you don't absolutely have to tell
that you pulled a deadly weapon on
another human being no matter how
justified you think it was and how
justified it in fact was reporting it
can do absolutely no good for you thank
you is it easier to see if you stand or
okay the you know first in again that
it's getting to a lot of topics here
there are a number of studies that show
opposite of what Gary says and these are
from other academics and in Gary gets
into long arguments and in journals and
magazine articles with with these other
academics who basically say that Gary is
not right that his methodology is not
right that actually when you look at
many of these studies that there are
more not only do we have more homicides
in this country and more gun homicides
generally they show that our homicide
rates are so much larger because of the
guns that if you take the guns out of it
we're you know we're the same level of
rapes we're the same level of robberies
are the same level of burglaries but we
are out of whack in terms of total
homicides and that is driven by the fact
that we have such high rates of gun
homicides and that's driven by the fact
that we have guns so yes if you don't
have guns you're not gonna have as many
gun homicides but
we are so much worse than the rest of
the developed world because we have so
many of these guns and that holds true
for the accidental deaths that holds
true accidental gun deaths that holds
true for the gun suicides that holds
true for these other things a lot of
times in the suicides again people are
looking for for a cry for help and maybe
there's some methods like hanging that
are close to guns but most people don't
go to that trouble most people are
trying pills most people are trying
knives those are the things that end up
at the 10 percent at the 20 percent
level in terms of gun bans again when I
was a Brady we supported Washington DC I
never but whenever I was asked that I
was said you know when I was mayor of
Fort Wayne when I pushed for a gun ban I
said no I don't think they're effective
but I said if the people of Washington
DC fill this is going to be effective
then they should make that decision and
they made that decision in the mid 1970s
they thought that maybe some of their
surrounding states and communities would
do the same thing they didn't it was
easy to get from Virginia it was easy to
get from Maryland and into DC so it was
pretty ineffective it actually did
reduce the number of suicides in DC
after it went into effect and actually
there's some evidence that reduced the
number of homicides in DC for for a
period of time but I told people if they
disagree to that they ought to run for
mayor of DC or for City Council in DC
instead they decided had the court
intervene and had the court get involved
in a study by the time I came up to the
city of McDonald versus the city of
Chicago case Brady took a neutral stance
on that brief because we felt that the
court's decision in Heller the DC case
was one that the court wasn't going to
say there's going to be one sets of
rules for DC and another set of rules
for every other city in the country
that just didn't make sense to us and we
also wanted to make sure that the people
really understood what the hell our
decision did and again we're not arguing
2nd amendment law here but the second
but the DC Court justice I mean the the
Supreme Court in the DC case Justice
Scalia made it very clear that the
Second Amendment right like other rights
is not unlimited
and that you could have restrictions on
who gets guns how guns are sold how guns
are carried how guns are stored and what
kind of guns are going to be available
to the people that's Justice Scalia's
decision that that's that's what Justice
Scalia wrote
that same languages was basically
repeated by justice alito two years
later in the McDonald case so clearly
communities states can put restrictions
on guns and I think that's the real
issue here what sort of things can we do
to try to make it harder for dangerous
people to get guns since the last time
I've debated Gary we've had shootings at
Sandy Hook shooting at Tucson with Gabby
Giffords we had the pulse nightclub
shooting nightclub shooting we had the
Las Vegas shooting we've had numerous
church shootings and what have we done
as a country in reaction to that nothing
nothing we've passed no national
legislation a few executive orders that
President Obama tried after Sandy Hook
have been rescinded since that time
we've done nothing as a country and we
still have problems here and IIIi don't
think that makes sense to me there are
things we can do and Gary admits it in
some of his articles background checks
aren't gonna stop people from having
good defensive gun uses most of the
there are no I don't think Gary showed
any defensive gun uses with
semi-automatic assault you know
so-called assault rifles the IRA ar-15
those aren't used for defensive purposes
if we make it if we have some background
checks if we have some restrictions on
weapons
you know the Gabby Giffords shooter was
was stopped when he was going to change
his magazine clip his and if he'd he'd
had a smaller magazine clip he would
have might not have killed that little
girl might have a shot less people the
Sandy Hook kids as some of them got away
when he went to change his high-capacity
magazine those sorts of things do make a
difference I think as a country we
should look at some common-sense
restrictions they make it harder for
dangerous people to get guns that stress
that there are risks and
responsibilities as well as rights that
go along with guns and that are not
going to take away the chance for people
to have good defensive gun uses if they
need it
we're going to the Q&A section
I might there might be moderators
prerogative to ask a couple of questions
as I plan to do but first at any time
you can ask question of each other do
you Gary or Paul want to ask the other
question this moment we want to pass for
the moment on that sure I'll ask a
couple of questions okay go ahead number
one as the Brady campaigns attitude
towards Washington's handgun ban they
did write an amicus curiae our brief but
did that say absolutely nothing about
whether or not the Brady Campaign
thought that this was an effective way
of controlling violence is that your
position now that the brief did not
advocate this would be a good idea from
a standpoint of policy the the brief
addressed the legal issues the Second
Amendment issues which is what legal
briefs do they don't discuss the policy
implications of it we indicated that we
thought that the the Second Amendment
because it had that preparatory clause
that says a well-regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
State language that somehow disappears
from the NRA building and many of the
the Second Amendment discussions because
that it dealt with a collective right
somehow connected to a militia that's
was that was the main argument in a
legal brief policy arguments are made by
City Council's and mayors and by
Congress we were discussing the legal
issues in the brief and then most of the
briefs I don't think on any side really
went into the effectiveness Justice
Breyer and his dissent did try to look
at an interest balancing thing brought
up a number of those things and there
are people that brought those issues up
as to the amount of gun violence in our
community but the crucial issue in front
of the court in Heller was not the
policy decision it was what does the
Second Amendment mean I think the court
got it wrong but I think they've allowed
for most of the common-sense gun
restrictions that most states want to do
okay the second question was you say
that somewhere in my article about how
many defensive gun uses there were that
I said defensive gun you saved 400,000
lies is this really something I said or
is this something you're kind of reading
into it well I was reading it at 12:30
at night so it very no
but on its I've actually got the page
number here the on page 177 of your of
the article you that was published in
1995 with Gertz in the Journal of
Criminology which i think is the first
main one that had the your your survey
on page
when I write this at that late at night
it gets ok page 177 15.7% of the politte
of the respondents believed that they
saved a life with their defensive gun
use and then you said that would
calculate to three hundred and forty
thousand to four hundred and thousand
saved lives and then you say it's
impossible to know that this is true but
that's that's it well it's I mean
basically you were saying you couldn't
believe your own numbers and then at the
end of your article what you did is is
you basically said I can't believe my
respondents so I'm only gonna believe
and then you know they just you you said
that if you okay you said even if
they're not telling the truth if only
ten percent of them are telling the
truth that would translate to forty
thousand saved lives which is more than
the number of gun deaths in a year and
that therefore defensive gun uses made
sense so you had a very long discussion
on this on page 177 right which included
the the follow-up remarks which you've
snipped out of the quote or paraphrase
or whatever you want to call that well
this is these are this what think he's
just their perceptions and I any
stressed you can't know that they would
have saved a life and they're thankful
life if they didn't use guns but but you
in short I did not in any way shape or
failure studies a defensive gun you say
four hundred thousand okay so that's
just something you made up okay but you
say that there's 2.5 million or
defensive gun uses I prepared it by all
sorts of politicians they don't include
the other thing too that maybe these
people don't really do anything with
this since half of the people don't you
know aren't even saying that they've got
a gun there well that's it that's
actually segues into the question I want
to put to you Gary having to do with
Paul's challenge he said specifically
let's assume for the moment that your
two million ballpark wanted two million
estimate is true okay but what is the
nature of this defensive gun usually
then broke it down and said it's not
really what you and I would think of as
defensive gun use can you adjust that
challenging force no in every single
case they did something with the gun
they at minimum threaten the offender
and in a few cases really just a small
percentage of the cases maybe one in
seven they they fired at the offender
trying to shoot the offender and then
maybe 7% of the cases they claimed to
have shot the offender but unfortunately
we never establish how they knew that I
mean you know they didn't have a wounded
person sitting on their living room
floor necessarily bleeding on the carpet
they were just in many cases just
guessing so what we knew is that at
minimum they threatened the offender
with the gun and it's not just saying as
a sort of point of information I've got
a gun it's threatening the person there
is a difference it's not a point of
information when you're pointing a gun
at somebody who's trying to rob you or
trying to attack you it has a meaning
due to its context and its meaning is
this is a threat I'm willing to shoot
you if you don't stop trying to victim
or that's what they think they were
doing only half of them pointed the gun
you say in your survey that you count
I've got a gun as being a defensive gun
use you know that I'm going it's a
verbal threat okay if you're trying to
say that they're not all dramatic I mean
they don't all involve you know attempts
to physically assault the other person
absolutely I said that from the get-go
but you seem to think there's no value
in people merely threatening an offender
and then it causes them to not attack
them no it's it's especially I I concede
there are good defensive gun uses but
when somehow you're 2.4 2.5 million
dollar defensive gun uses has become
locked into the consciousness of the gun
rights arguments in this country and it
turns out that a lot of this is just
macho I've got a gun get away or you
know even though only 18 percent of you
have a gun you better get out of there
because I maybe half of them
half of your respondents think they
pointed the gun at the person we're
talking about something different I mean
when I took when I think about defensive
gun use I'm thinking about someone who's
got a gun shows the gun
maybe points the gun not necessarily
shoots the gun brandishing does count
but half appear people didn't even point
the gun at the person I'm not you know I
think we're living in a bit of a dream
world here and again we're only talking
about two hundred and twenty two
respondents that admitted that these
were the defensive guns you do realize
so down to the hundred and eleven who
said they pointed the gun then you're
getting down to the forty or what a
thirty that actually you know she you
know had an attack going on we're
talking about pretty small numbers here
you do realize as a lawyer that if
somebody verbally threatens another
person with violence that is an assault
and if it's a criminal assault when a
bad guy does it for bad purposes why is
it in your mind it's magically
transmitted translated into not a real
threat not unless he actually points the
gun but verbally threatening to shoot
somebody that doesn't count in your mind
now I know clearly that's a threat but
I'm just it's work I think we're mixing
different things and people have taken
year 2.4 million figure and translated
it into they need their ak-47 to be able
to shoot back when the gang is invading
their house - all of a sudden I saw
somebody trespassing so I said I've got
a gun get out of my backyard well my
question to you is let's say it is a
half a million to a million let's cut to
half a million to a million let's settle
3/4 defensive gun uses that you Paul
Humphrey would say is legitimately a
defensive gun use you you seem to have
said you don't rule that out no no no
but if you don't rule it out if it's
three quarters of a million and it's
reasonable defensive gun uses isn't that
very considerably weighing in the
balance in your view if you believe that
number which you haven't well it's it's
mine I'm approaching this issue as yes
guns can be used for beneficial purposes
and Gary's outlined some of those but
also guns can be used for very negative
purposes and I tried out loan the those
and I'm not taking a prohibitions
prohibitionist approach I'm saying let's
make it let's
do more background checks lick its let's
get some of these things like some of
the semi-automatic assault rifles and
the high-capacity magazines and perhaps
treat those closer to how we treat
machine guns and how we treat hunting
rifles let's go habit though let's go
after gun trafficking and do some things
that are gonna make it harder for
dangerous people to get guns and stress
the risks and the responsibilities of
gun ownership and then maybe we end up
ahead but instead we do nothing is
before the questions is the final
question thrown to you Gary
is there any restriction legal
restrictions on gun use that you support
any at all yeah since the at least going
back as far as the early 90s Oh over a
quarter of a century ago I've advocated
what today has become known as universal
background check I'm all in favor of
keeping guns away from bad guys
precisely because that's not a
prohibitionist member measure it's not
like we're not gonna let anybody
criminal or non criminal have a
semi-automatic weapon because it kind of
looks like a machine gun when we know
perfectly well what that means is mostly
to disarming on criminals but a
background check it only prevents guns
from going in the hands of people who
can't fail the back can't pass the
background check which is convicted
criminals people with a record of mental
illness and so on alcoholics drug
addicts and so forth and so it's the non
prohibition as character that makes it a
good idea because it will only reduce
bad uses of guns and won't reduce the
defense's and that's the main
legislative priority that the Brady
Campaign had over the last 10 20 25
years since the Brady Bill was passed
and that's something that we can't get
Congress to adopt and we need more
people like Jerry Clark and others to
stand up and say that makes sense
questions from the audience now or do
you have anybody out there it's a little
dark
please phrase your question as a
question take it away mr. mayor what
kind of what kind of restrictions or
regulations would you propose or you
think would help with the suicides or
the domestic situations types of
shootings
what kind of data is there that they
would actually help decrease those
numbers it's a it's kind of you know
obviously the laws aren't going to take
care of all the you know or even close
to these these problems that it's more
the gun culture and the idea that having
a gun in your home is going to protect
you all the time
and not realizing that that gun is gonna
cause problems I've told the story
before when I was mayor I get a call one
night one of my police officers as
married - he's my labor relations
director at the time he's married to
another police officer they keep a
loaded handgun on their on their
nightstand because it's a dangerous
world out there and their policing
they're trained they have a domestic
moral she's dead you know that's what
happens it's a guns just have a lot of
bad consequences to them one of the
things you know some people propose
waiting periods that that might get
someone who's just got a quick you know
I'm you know it all is lost I need to
commit suicide and it'll stop there and
that might stop someone else I I think a
lot of it just deals with the that
stress the the responsibilities let's
stress the risks that go with guns let's
realize that that these can be misused
instead we've got an attitude in this
country that anyone should pretty much
have any gun anytime anyplace
coming from you Gary to the question no
no comment Gary no okay next question I
did a quick search after your comment
about the number of accidental gun
shootings per day and it turns out in
2016 there about 37,000 accidental
deaths resulting from automobiles I
think I do the division right that's
about a hundred a day I'm not gonna ask
you why you don't advocate more
common-sense automobile regulation what
I want to ask you is your use of
anecdotes are tragic and heart-wrenching
why do gun control advocates have to
provide data like that much of which has
been discredited by people like Gary in
order to make your argument why can't
you look at the same data and make the
same argument with valid useful data
okay let me do talk about cars just real
quickly just because it comes up all the
time
we register cars so we know who the
owner is we license the drivers and have
tests on that I think registration of
guns and licensing of gun owners might
make some sense when we find out that
that someone that a driver is misusing
alcohol or drugs we take their license
away from them we test to see if they
know what they're doing and they're
driving a car when we find out that cars
are unsafe we start requiring things
like air bags and seat belts and get rid
of the pintos they explode the types of
things we have done a lot to reduce car
violence by looking at both the people
that drive the car and the cars
themselves that's a good approach to
take that's a public health approach to
toward things guns I'd like to take the
same approach toward let's figure out a
public health model and figuring out
what we can do part of the problem is is
there it's tough to find good research
for a long time and maybe this is
changing for a long time basically
Congress had riders on some bills that
made it almost impossible or at least
conveyed the message that the CDC the
National Institute of Health could not
do the research so people had to
research on their own and then if they
read that and then the research becomes
suspect I'd like to see more research
done on this and if the data takes us
someplace let's do it the one thing that
is pretty clear is the number of deaths
that are occurring that's data that's
incontrovertible that's one of the most
solid things that's not based on survey
that's you know maybe they can fudge
some numbers that's what I'm relying and
I'm relying on the number of people that
are killed with guns each day and then
you try to figure out where did the gun
come from are there things that could
have been done all of that is hard to
research by the way too because Congress
has also made it hard to trace where
guns come from you can find out where a
single gun comes from but you can't get
information on whether that gun stores
sold all the other guns used in crime so
we make it almost impossible to get the
data we do that so that way you can't
develop a policy prescription that deals
with guns coming
well Paul admits to an advocacy of
registration and there's a difference
between registering cars and registering
guns and the difference is nobody
seriously advocating banning cars I mean
maybe you know the really green people
would think there's something to be said
for that but there
small minority but there are lots of
people who do support banning guns and
certainly about half will support
banning semi-automatic guns that get
labeled as Misawa weapons and about a
quarter will still support banning
handguns although the number is
declining so yeah people want to ban it
and what would you need administrative
Lee if you wanted to seize all the guns
or all the handguns or all the assault
weapons or all the large capacity
magazines well you would need a record
of who has them there may be a law
enforcement or governmental
impossibility to basically know who owed
you a gun and who should turn it in if
you declare you have to turn in let's
say an assault weapon which is exactly
what's happened
Datta California said turn in your
assault weapons whatever they were and
how would they know whether you had one
and should be turning it in well the
only way the government can know that is
if they have a record of it and that's
what registration is it records who has
specific guns it doesn't have any crime
control value every single study that
successed the impact of registration
laws on crime rates has found there's no
effect of having a registration law on
crime rates so it's got no crime control
rationale but it's got plenty of
rationale making banning some subset of
guns administrative leafies about the
first of all the Supreme Court in the
Heller case and the McDonald case made
it clear that you can't ban guns so I
mean it's the night after the Heller
case I congratulate Wayne LaPierre or
said you okay you got what you wanted
then the Supreme Court said the remedy
for dick Heller was that he should have
his a get the license for his gun said
why don't we move forward then with a
licensing or registration scheme oh no I
can't do that they still might try to
take our guns away some constitutional
supreme courts behind you on this sort
of thing and then I point out that the
most avid gun rights folks I usually
deal with all have concealed carry
permits which means the government has
their name with the lists of concealed
carry permits and they don't like that
either and and well but they've got it
out there and then I point out in this
day and age if when the when not the
government one Facebook and
and what Twitter and everybody else can
figure out what kind of toothpaste to
use what kind of deodorant use what kind
of magazines you get where are you back
you can find out pretty much everything
about everybody you don't think someone
can figure out who the likely gun owners
are in the country the idea that the gun
registration is some Bugaboo that the
government's going to take your guns
away I I think that's leftover from the
from centuries or you know from decades
past so as a lawyer you think that that
kind of information that's sort of
floating around on the internet would be
enough for a court to issue a search
warrant so they're not they're not gonna
do that because they can't you can't
have gun bans for constitutionally now
I'm pretty sure a registration form by
the government would be a pretty good
basis for probable cause day next
question somewhat related to the
registration question but more generally
for the entire restriction question what
do you think the effectiveness of any of
these laws are going to be in the face
of 3d printed guns and CNC milled
question about printed guns and I feel I
seemingly everybody wants to ask you a
question Paul it's okay change your
format I wish I knew more about it but
it's it's one of those things where
first of all the cat's already out of
the bag or the horse is out of the
corral or whatever the the euphemism is
it's you know the the information won't
die it's on the internet it's
circulating the the plans are there the
programming to make your your 3d printer
crank out the the weaponry yeah is there
but you know does anybody really want
one I mean that's that was my initial
reaction when I first heard about
somebody saying well you get 3d print a
gun why would you want one I mean first
of all most 3d printers they crank out
plastic do you really want a gun that's
going to melt after firing two or three
times and especially are you going to
want one when there's 350 million real
guns out there made out of steel and
wood and plastic and all sorts are
really durable stuff why would you need
or
this so I think you know it's it's kind
of gun anarchists out there who are
pushing the idea of putting out these 3d
manufactured guns it's of symbolic
significance I guess to a libertarian
audience it's it's thumbing your nose at
the government maybe maybe that's what
it's really all about but I don't see it
as being of any practical significance
all right comment Paul is gonna say it
it did I think the significant thing is
how this is going to change in the
future I mean if you get to the stage
right now as I understand it a lot of
these plastic guns aren't aren't as
durable they're not as reliable they
might be only good for one or two uses
then they might explode or overheat or
whatever that you still need a metal
firing pin ursa need some mother metal
attached to it to make them more
effective I don't know why anyone would
do it I used to give a speech and
actually I think it's kind of
interesting it's trying to understand I
mean all guns ignoring the 3d guns
basically all guns start out in the
legal market how do they end up in the
hands of the bad guys and it's something
I think we should study I mean
oftentimes they're stolen from the good
guy with the gun who buys the first
defensive gun use Gleason's cars get
stolen losing his home and get stolen
this sort of thing and I'd point out
that you don't really have gangs in the
basements in Chicago making guns well
now theoretically you can have gangs
making the guns and you know that might
change the mix but I that still years
away I think but you know it's if it
ever gets the stage where you could
easily make an effective multi-use gun
on your own I think it's gonna make it I
mean the debates gonna be a lot
different next question I this questions
for Paul since you mentioned mass
shootings it seems to be the case that a
lot of these shootings might have been
prevented if already existing laws were
probably enforced properly and
effectively ofourse I'm curious as to
why you're advocating for additional
sorry regulations and restrictions if
it's the case that there are already
existing laws might have already
prevented these laws if they were
probably for so I'm not sure what laws
you're talking about other than laws
against murder yeah it's against the law
to murder somebody but it's a the
laws serve a number of purposes you know
laws hopefully are written to try to
prevent crimes bad things from occurring
laws are also written when a bad thing
occurs then you've got a legal right to
arrest that person and charge them for
it
laws also sort of set what communities
what society's norms are for behavior
the what's a lot of the mass shootings
though basically the person didn't break
any law at all that the Gabby Giffords
shooter Arizona basically has no laws on
the books or with regard to guns he
wasn't breaking a single law carrying
the gun carrying a loaded gun carry
waving the loaded gun he didn't break
the law till he pulled the trigger the
first time and again he he wasn't
stopped by the good guy with the gun
around the corner he was stopped when
the magazine ran out of the bullets and
he got tackled by by some 65 year old
type person so the the the Sandy Hook
shooter the old people yeah the the
Sandy Hook shooter his mother had a good
collection of guns that didn't do her
any good he used one of them to shoot
her and then he goes to the school to
shoot people and again you had some of
the school kids get away when he had
went to change the magazine out because
the magazine only held 31 bullets uh you
know if he'd had a smaller magazine that
was capped at 10 or 15 or 18 more people
might have gotten away to I mean when
laws have problems then you strengthen
the laws just just one real quick
example one of the few gun control laws
we have on the books is the Gun Control
Act of 1968 it set the list of
prohibited purchasers felons people who
are dangerously mentally ill for 25
years basically the way it operated is
they'd say if I went in to buy a gun
they'd say Paul or you found I say no
they say here's your gun I mean it's I'd
have to fill out the rest of the form
but they just relied on my say-so
obviously bad people can lie so the
Brady Bill that started to have
background checks from from federally
licensed dealers said let's do a check
on this sort of thing we didn't say gee
that prohibitive purchaser law doesn't
work let's get rid of it they said let's
figure out what we need to do by going
to the federally licensed gun dealers
who presumably are law-abiding to figure
out what they can do when we have
something that's not working and bad
things
happen look to see if you need to change
the law strength of law get rid of the
law and halves try something else but
instead we just basically say laws are
no good we can't do anything what was us
let's get more guns and you know like I
always say if more guns made us safer
we'd be the safest country in the world
and we're not yeah the the one specific
gun control measure that Paul mentions
that the Brady Campaign and other gun
control organizations mentioned is a ban
on large capacity magazines the idea
being that if these mass shooters had
magazines that held no more than ten
rounds which is the usual cutoff for
these bans then they'd hurt fewer people
so the argument it's a subtle one but
it's well there's there's no real
difference between a guy who has thirty
rounds in three separate magazines each
holding ten rounds versus a guy who has
a single 30 round magazine it's not the
difference in rounds that matters it's
the fact that the guy who has only ten
round magazines he has to reload more
often so that's why Paul keeps citing
that one example of gabrielle giffords
somebody tackled the shooter while he
was reloading the problem is a we don't
really know that's what happened he he
may well have been struggling with a
with a defective magazine and that's why
they were able to tackle him in other
words it had nothing to do with him
trying to reload as far as we know maybe
that was the case but there is to my
knowledge in the past thirty years not a
single case of somebody who actually got
tackled while they were reloading so the
fact that a ban on big magazines would
make the shooter reload more often it
doesn't have the significance he's
hinting and he also says that in the
Sandy Hook shooting a bunch of school
kids escaped while the guy was reloading
we in fact haven't the slightest
evidence that's what was happening we
don't know whether he was just choosing
to stop shooting for a while whether he
was taking a break to you know wipers
the perspiration off his forehead we
have no idea there's no evidence
whatsoever that his reloading efforts
had absolutely anything
with those kids escaping next question
thank you Paul you you mentioned too
that you mentioned a lot of the school
shootings as example I like Sandy Hook
and you said you know we didn't have a
good guy with the gun stopping the
shootings he also earlier compared us
statistics too and I quote us other
civilized countries so my question is
would you then support the law that
would actually repealed the law that
didn't allow a good guy with a gun to
stop the shootings because of the the
guaranteed victim or the gun-free school
zones act which is why we couldn't have
a good guy with the gun stopping
shootings and could you also define what
a civilized country is since you
compared the United States and I meant
developed countries and then I tried to
clarify that when I when I was speaking
and it's generally they look at 25 and
other industrialized countries when
they're doing these comparisons the
other comparison was to like Canada New
Zealand and Australia because they had
sort of the frontier settlement
background that we had the I don't you
know I have no objection to schools
hiring school resource officers bringing
in police officers to deal with with the
pasta when there's a threat to deal with
the possibility of a threat to deal with
the school shootings I am opposed to
having teachers given the responsibility
of doing this my wife was a teacher for
37 years
it was tough enough to keep your purse
secure the much less a gun secure in the
classroom I've talked to people that
have been shot in injured at Virginia
Tech and and other school shooting
situations and some of these people are
people that were familiar with guns you
had used guns new guns and they've
indicated that the gun would have done
nothing for them would've only made them
an earlier target and in situations it's
a
you know if we're gonna have it that
there's a threat someplace get someone
who's trained to handle that threat to
that place to deal with it that that's
how you handle these situations there's
a you know you're never gonna have a
perfect situation again we're always
hoping that the heroes there someplace
but in in real life it that's that's
hard to have adding more guns to the
situation just ends up usually having
more things go wrong I might is anyone
here been in a school when there's been
a school shooting there's not okay the
the the gentleman in the back okay
Barbara's the one I use they bring up at
like when I'm speaking to college
campuses because a lot of times they'll
talk about you know college kids should
be able to have their concealed carry
permit and I talk about you know the
folks have gone to year school generally
and have not not many people have ever
been in the school shooting there's more
now than there used to be then I say you
know how many of you in college do
anyone who ever got drunk how many of
you in college knew anyone that abused
drugs how many in college knew anyone
who was seriously depressed and then or
had relationship issues whatever and
then you add into that that the fact
that college dorms are not very secure
and that classrooms don't have places to
store things you know the idea of adding
more guns into a college setting or even
a pre-cut you know K through 12 setting
I don't think makes sense unless you're
hiring professionals to be they're
coming okay yeah Paul argues that the
reason why you can't have you know
authorized teachers or security officers
with guns in a school is because you
can't secure the gun
if you can't secure a purse how can you
secure a gun there's a simple device
called a trigger lock which is it just
goes behind the trigger and it makes it
utterly impossible to fire the gun
whether you're a kid in a classroom or
anybody else if you're not the
authorized user who doesn't have a key
to stick in that lock you're not gonna
be able to use it to my knowledge in 40
years of research I've never heard of a
single documented case where somebody
defeated a trigger lock and then did
harm with the gun were an unauthorized
got ahold of the gun and disengaged the
trigger lock that is they didn't commit
homicides they can commit suicides and
they didn't commit an accidental death
or injury with the gun so that's not a
that's not an issue but the fact that
people have to make up these spurious
reasons why you couldn't have an
authorized shooter just shows the
weaknesses of the argument it's not like
every school teacher would be packing a
gun in their hip the usual proposal is
there was one or two people who have
been trained often because they're
former military or police who are the
authorized accessors of the gun and
there may be one or two guns in the
entire school and they're secure with
either a locked cabinet or a trigger
lock and so the idea that well the
problem is somebody'll on all authorized
will get a hold of the gun and god knows
what will happen it's it's not an issue
I mean if you want to think if you want
to argue well then they'd be surprised
or shocked and they wouldn't have the
frame of mind to use the gun effectively
that's possible that's a plausible
argument but the idea that you couldn't
secure the gun or these proposals entail
all the teachers being armed and packing
a gun on their hip that's crazy that has
nothing to do with the real debate next
question thank you guys
my question is to the both of you seems
as both of you are okay with background
checks and you happen to make Equipe
about gangs and chicago print and guns
so I guess that's a little allusion to
the black communities in Chicago that
are experiencing gun violence by gangs
so my question I'm gonna frame this
question under New York State gun
control laws so in New York State
you have to put up seven hundred dollar
registration fee to get a to get a
permit you need seven pieces of
municipal ID seven pieces of ID outside
of your municipal ID to get a to get a
permit and apparently asking for ID for
voting is racist so imagine seven piece
of ID you can get denied for your gun
permit
if you have us if you were convicted of
a single felony in your previous life I
mean in your previous before you know
applying for that permanent you could
still get denied so it seems to me that
these sort of laws really these gun
control laws in New York really only
affect communities of color because most
gun legal gun owners in New York are
white so I would like to know would you
be well either of you guys be in support
of repealing New York's racist gun laws
um thankfully this will be have to be
the last question
once you carry you as you go first with
that question and then Paul and then
we'll have a summation yeah well
unfortunately it doesn't apply just to
racial minorities it applies to
everybody it's almost impossible for a
middle-class white person to get a
permit in in the city of New York and
it's it's the city more than the rest of
the state of New York and the questioner
did accurately portray just how very
difficult it is furthermore it can be
denied on totally subjective grounds
somebody in the police department can
say I don't think this person has a
reasonable basis or sufficient
reasonable basis to get a carry a permit
and there is no specific criteria that
are articulated in the law it's it can
be a completely arbitrary subjective
judgment and yes when you have that kind
of discretion anybody who happens to be
personally personally racially biased or
for that matter gender biased can easily
let those those biases influence that
subjective a judgment which is quite
different from the standard background
check where it's cut and dried you
either have a criminal conviction or you
don't if you do you can't get the the
gun the permit whatever and if you're
clean then you can go ahead and get it
but New York City's laws are remarkably
subjective come in Paul just first of
all anyone who has a felony regardless
of how long ago it is is banned it
cannot buy a gun
much less get it that permit to carry
that's and that's federal law so that's
a that's one of the things that goes
back to the Gun Control Act of 1968
the the Supreme Court has not yet ruled
on the issue of whether there's a
constitutional right to carry again
outside of your house both the Heller
case and the McDonald case said you had
a right to have a gun in your home for
self defense so we're not really getting
into the constitutional issues I've
generally and I don't know the details
of New York so carry laws I generally
support may issue States rather than
shall issue states where the sheriff or
the police chief can have a chance to
deny someone because oftentimes they're
gonna have information that might not be
a formal disqualifier for buying a gun
but they'll know that they've responded
twenty-five domestic arguments to that
place or they've got neighbors that know
that say drugs are being sold there or
they they have arrested this person five
or six times but don't have a it might
be on a misdemeanor charge that involves
violence but not enough to make them
borrow them for caring I do think that
the way to counteract a subjective
discrimination would be to have some
sort of an appeal process for those
things and that doesn't bother me but
generally I trust of the sheriffs and
the police chiefs to have a better sense
of who should be able to carry loaded
guns in public and therefore endanger
the rest of us and I think it's a good
way to go thank you Paul summations you
have five minutes to summarize you can
take the podium or you can do it from
the chair prefer to do it I'm still lazy
we're gonna do it from the chair you
know the the debate is the really
technical debate is too boring to talk
about but you know in a way this issue
really boils down to how much defense of
gun use there is and it's it's a mark of
how threatening large numbers of
defensive gun uses is to the pro control
movement that they make they go to such
great lengths to discredit large
estimates Paul seriously suggest that
you can count up defensive gun uses by
counting up how many news articles there
are about them
he doesn't actually quite say I believe
that in fact he kind of hints he doesn't
believe it but why bring it up he offers
the National Crime Victimization survey
estimate of a hundred thousand offensive
gun uses but that survey has never asked
a single respondent a direct question
about defensive gun use they're only
counting up how many people kind of
volunteer the information that they
pointed a deadly weapon at another human
being and not surprisingly in a
government-run government-sponsored
survey which is not anonymous where they
know where you live and your telephone
number and name and so on people are not
really inclined to volunteer that
information that survey has nothing to
say in this debate but there are 20
national surveys plus 20 plus that have
without exception indicated defensive
gun use is really common and why is this
surprising millions of Americans tens of
millions of Americans maybe hundreds of
thousands of Americans own guns and
there's a lot of crime out there where
you'd have an opportunity and a need to
use a gun for self-protection so this is
a fact that needs to be taken account of
in making policy you shouldn't be making
policy that cuts into people using guns
for self protective purposes where
they're not killing people to protect
themselves
they're just avoiding death and injury
themselves for the most part by pointing
a gun at a criminal and saying knock it
off and so I don't have any problem at
all with with gun control measures that
are selectively aimed at bad guys
including convicted felons and including
people who have been declared to be
dangerous to themselves and others by a
court of law I have no problem with that
either but what I do have a problem with
is laws that will disarm more people
whether it be of all guns or handguns or
so-called assault weapons or large
capacity magazines it'll do this more
for non criminals and for criminals all
of that is bad policy poorly thought-out
and not supported by the best available
evidence so let's put together some
good policy that's going to try to
reduce the number of deaths the number
of injuries and costs of having guns but
still not take the guns away that are
going to be used for defensive gun
purposes gary concedes that background
checks make sense there we haven't had
we've discussed a so-called assault
weapons there's no evidence I don't
think at least in the the early thing I
read maybe it's because of the it was
written in the mid 90s that that the
so-called assault weapons were used for
defensive purposes I mean most of the
time the person was first of all waving
a handgun I think that was the most
prevalent that you had under the chart
in front of me now they well no yeah no
you on your chart yet you do you've been
your survey you indicate if you
responded to the offender forty eight
percent of whom didn't have a gun with a
gun what kind of or with the weapon what
kind of weapon did you have and they
list baseball bats knives handguns that
they don't list a assault rifle so
that's a you know so so what what I'm
saying is that we we can form you know
we can structure some things
registration and licensing if we go
there shouldn't be taking the guns away
from good people should be helping us
track who actually owns the gun and
where it's going laws on reporting lost
and stolen guns wouldn't do something
laws requiring guns to be locked up like
Gary suggests for schools might make
some sense there are things we can do
but what we're doing is nothing we're
allowing people to basically buy any
kind of gun the any number of these guns
as they can and then you know we end up
with the cost of it and a lot of times I
think what we haven't talked about
tonight either is is how these defensive
gun uses sometimes in their in in and of
themselves cause problems I think in one
of Gary's calms he talks about maybe it
was thirty three percent our bad guy
versus bad guy defensive gun uses you
get sometimes where basically you get an
arms race or an escalation of the
conflict because of the gun I mean look
at the the George Zimmerman Trayvon
Martin situation you know here's
something that should have at the worst
been a fight and at trave and George
Zimmerman pulls out the gun and Trayvon
Martin's dead
you get the situation the other day
somebody comes to their house and the
doors open so they pull their gun and
they shoot and it turns out it's a
Dallas police officer and she's in the
wrong room you know these are from what
people considered offensive gun uses
having that gun makes someone more
willing to pull the gun more willing to
shoot the gun more willing to escalate
situations that shouldn't be again I
concede I admit I agree there are good
purposes used for guns
I'm not anti-gun but I think we can we
need to realize that when we as a
society allow people to have an
instrument that can kill others kill
many others kill them at a distance and
particularly we allow people to carry
those loaded in public thereby impacting
others either accidentally or
intentionally or negligently or
recklessly then we as a society I think
have an appropriate chance to respond to
that it's not a constitutional issue
it's one that requires some research it
requires some good policy my bottom line
tonight is let's let's let's not take
away good defensive gun uses let's try
to get some more effective gun laws that
will make it harder for dangerous people
to get guns let's lift the prohibitions
on studying these issues and treat this
as a public health issue and try to make
it safer for all of us
instead everybody goes to their corner
I'm all for guns or I'm all against guns
I don't know anyone who wants to ban all
guns I don't know anyone who wants
everyone to have every gun there is
there should be plenty of room for
middle ground here let's decide which
people should be restricted right now we
restrict felons dangerously mentally ill
and some others let's see if some
violent misdemeanors should be put in
that category and maybe some tax cheat
felons should be taken off of that
category you know you can look at who
gets guns let's look at the types of
guns right now we restrict machine guns
fully automatic we've done that since
the mid nineteen thirties been effective
you don't see machine guns used in bank
robberies anymore let's decide a
semi-automatic so I ought to be treated
more like machine guns or create new
rules for them you know let's go through
those categories where should guns be
excluded
how should be able to carry a gun what
kind of guns should be out there those
are the sorts of things that the Supreme
Court says
our constitutionally permissible those
are things that could be effective those
are things that should be studied this
shouldn't be the hot-button issue that
we make it out to Gary and I shouldn't
have to come back ten years from now
having the same argument that we had ten
years ago thank you for being here okay
Brent you're ready to bring the results
okay please bring a lot
all right the initial vote in favor of
the resolution was forty five point
fifty nine percent that rose to fifty
percent so the yes votes picked up six
point four one percent that's the number
to beat the no votes were thirty three
point 33 and declined slightly to 33
point seventy seven down to point five
six percent it looks like the yes gets
the tootsie roll congratulation gallery
you